Pock, Pock Pock
Pock Pock Pock
Baschen alter Baschen
Pock Pock Pock Pock Pock
Garefire
Pock Pock
Dennis ist zum ersten Mal am Start
Jonas auch zum ersten Mal am Start
Huge
Der Icefreak hat subscribt
Jojo hat subscribt
Gehts aber ab hier
Das Scam Train fährt
So, jetzt habe ich mich ein bisschen
ausgelassen über die Bahn
und alte Handys
Übrigens Leute
Soll ich euch mal erzählen, was ich gerade
Ich hab gerade richtig, richtig nice
Futterstells gemacht
Ich hab Pizza, Hut
Barbecue
Barbecue Bacon Lovers
gefuddert
Falle dir aus Deinen für den Sub
Excellent
Er ist da
Max, mach mal
Shoutout an mich
Nein, ich mach keine Shoutouts
Weißt du warum?
Weil die Leute mittlerweile krass
Chebaten, was Usernamen angeht
Und ich mir immer Gedanken
mache, dass wenn man den Usernamen falsch
ausspricht, dass man dann irgendwas
Bannwürdiges sagen kann
Aber ich kann
Shoutout an den
Das Serif machen, oder? Das ist kein Problem
Aber ich spreche das
bestimmt nicht komplett aus
Wer weiß, was das falsch betont bedeutet
Ja
Werden sie
Guck mal
Das ist so ein Fond von Google
Fonds
Ich, ich traue
der ganzen Sache nicht
Macht Twitch das mit Bots?
Na ja, das wären schon richtige
Leute, seien wir mal ernsthaft
Ich gehe davon aus, dass von
wir grad 210 Leute im Chat. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass bei jedem Streamer, sag mal
so, selbst bei ganz kleinen, dass es einen gewissen Anteil der Zuschauer gibt, die nicht
zuschauen, weil sie den Streamer gerne zugucken, sondern weil sie ihn hassen und einfach nur
warten, dass er irgendwie Scheiße baut, um ihn dann zu reporten. 100 Pro, das gibt's
bei mir und es gibt es wahrscheinlich überall anders auch. Richtige Hater, genau. Die gucken
den Stream nur, dass irgendwie einer was falsch betont, was falsch ausspricht, dann gleich
report, report, report, report, report. Und wenn er dann gebannt wird, dann geht ihn einer
ab. So sieht's aus. So, ich zeig euch jetzt mal was. Also, ich switche mal kurz auf die
Kamera. Hast du mal Windows Subsystem für Android probiert? Nein, gibt's das mittlerweile?
Ich dachte, das gibt's gar nicht. Das haben sie abgeschafft wieder. Also, ich zeig euch
jetzt mal was. Bevor wir zur Steckdosenleiste kommen, ich zeig euch noch mal kurz was anderes.
Oder auch nicht mein Finger, den habt ihr ja mittlerweile oft genug gesehen. Ups. Ich
zeig euch was anderes. Ich glaube, das ist das Richtige. Ja. Die waren nämlich diesmal
echt schnell. Ich hab ja ESPs bestellt, D1 Minis. Das hat jetzt nur ein paar Tage gedauert,
da waren die am Start 10 Stück. Poggers. Das heißt, da stehen irgendwelchen LED Projekten
und Dingern jetzt nichts mehr im Wege. Wir haben wieder alles, was wir brauchen. 10 D1
Minis für alle möglichen Sachen. Also, die waren wirklich schnell. So, und jetzt kommen
wir zur eigentlichen Sache, warum ich heute den Stream angemacht hab. Ich mach heute aber
nicht so viel Hektik. Ich bin echt ziemlich kaputt dank der Bahn und sinnlos in den Meer
gefahren, Leute. Ihr müsst euch das mal geben. Ich habe heute auf der Arbeit nichts gemacht,
weil ich musste, ich zeig es euch mal auf Twitter, den ganzen Tag total sinnlos mieten.
Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist doch nicht normal. Das war so schlimm. Ich hatte um 9 Uhr parallel
zwei Meetings gleichzeitig. Was soll das denn geben, wenn es fertig ist? Konntest du die
Meetings nicht auch digital machen? Doch, natürlich. Die waren ja auch alle digital.
Das ist der Witz. Es hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt, dass ich nach Frankfurt gefahren
bin. Alles war rein digital. Ich hab niemand, mit dem ich gemietet hab, wirklich vor Ort
gesehen. Komm mal, ich hab sogar zwei Meetings parallel gehabt um 9. Danach ging es weiter
um 10.30 Uhr. Ich kann euch ja sogar sagen, was das war. Hier ging es um Dokumentation,
also das Lieblingsthema eigentlich aller IT-Leute. Hier ging es um irgendwelche Dokumentationssachen
und automatischen Import aus irgendwelchen Azure Key Value Stores. Hab ich gesagt, ich
programmiere irgendwas. Was war denn das? Ach ja, hier ging es darum, dass die Leute
im Klartext irgendwelche Passwörter in ihren Repos gespeichert haben und festgestellt haben,
dass es keine so gute Idee ist, wenn wir unsere Passwörter auf Gitter pushen. Da hab ich mir
gedacht, ach, wer hätte sich das vorher nur denken können, dass das keine gute Idee ist,
als man die da reingeschrieben hat. Hier war unsere wöchentliche Wartungsarbeiten-Runde,
wo dann jeder aus jeder Abteilung einer da sitzt, oder von jedem Team sogar, einer da
sitzt. Da sind mittlerweile glaube ich 56 Leute eingeladen und ihre Wartungsarbeiten für die
Woche vorstellen müssen. Äußerst Residenz-Sleeper-Termin kann ich euch sagen, da penst wirklich einen
dabei. Vor allem, weil es immer Leute gibt, die aus Prinzip nachfragen müssen. Das nervt
mich. So total random. Leute, so ein Beispiel, was auf unsere Wartungsarbeiten runterkommt.
Ein Beispiel. Ich muss das jetzt ein bisschen abändern, dass man nicht so sehr auf die Firma
schließen kann. Es sagt zum Beispiel einer auf der Wartungsarbeiten-Runde, wir müssen
irgendwie Coopernetiskluster neu deployen. Irgendwas. Und dann sagt unser Oberwartungsarbeiten-Guru,
gibt es dazu noch irgendwelche Einwände, will dazu einer was sagen. Und dann kommt irgendjemand
um die Ecke, hat das Auswirkungen auf die Kantine-Speisekarte oder irgendwie sowas,
die gibt es bei uns elektronisch. So komplett planlose random Fragen kommen da immer. Es
hat auch schon mal einer gefragt, wir haben einen Standort in Frankreich, wir haben einen
Standort in Frankreich, wo besonders erfolgreiche Stonks-Leute quasi Urlaub gewinnen können,
wenn sie so und so viel Zeugs verkauft haben. Und da hat mal ernsthaft einer gefragt, da
hat auch jemand angekündigt, wir machen Wartungsarbeiten an Datenbanken. Und dann hat wirklich jemand
gefragt, hat das Auswirkungen auf den Standort in Frankreich. Hat das Auswirkungen auf die
Switche in Frankreich. Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht, Leute, ihr seid echt komplett
durch. Garantiert, der Switch im Hotel in Frankreich rebootet sich bestimmt, wenn einer bei uns
Datenbanken Wartungsarbeiten macht. Ganz sicher. 12.45 Uhr gab es Daily Team Meeting. 13 Uhr
bis 13.30 Uhr gab es wieder so eine Art Wartungsarbeiten Runde. Und 13.30 bis 14 Uhr habe ich vergessen,
weiß nicht, war ich wahrscheinlich geistig schon nicht mehr anwesend. Wie soll man da
produktiv arbeiten? Das ist ja der Trick, gar nicht. Es gibt zu viel Bullshit-Jobs und
Bullshit-Gramm, den man machen muss. Die wollen alle ihre Zeit irgendwie legitimieren, dass
sie ihre Daseinsberechtigung irgendwie, weiß nicht. Da kann man nicht produktiv arbeiten,
das funktioniert nicht. 15.50 Uhr, wisst ihr warum ich 15.50 Uhr bis 23 Uhr drinstehen
habe? Nein, bei uns sind Meetings überhaupt nicht aus. Warum ich da 15.50 Uhr drinstehen
habe, das habe ich blockiert, dass mich da keiner mehr einladen kann, weil wir hatten
an einer keine Bereitschaft. Bereitschaft mache ich nimmer freiwillig. Wenn es bezahlt
wird vielleicht, aber nimmer freiwillig. Früher habe ich sowas freiwillig gemacht. Ja, und
ich habe das eingetragen, dass ich dort nicht mehr eingeladen werden kann, weil wir hatten
so ein paar Kandidaten, die haben an 17 Uhr Meetings eingeladen und sowas. 17 Uhr, was
ist mit denen los? 17 Uhr mache ich gerade Pepofet was zu essen daheim und miete bestimmt
nicht mehr zu irgendwelchen sinnlosen Themen. Nee, das ist einfach nur Blocker, dass mich
keiner einladen kann. So, die stehen richtig auf Miete. Morgen ist nicht so schlimm, aber
heute war echt so ein krasser Tag. Willst du dich bei einer Firma bewerben, die einen
Scrum Master MWD sucht? Warum nicht? Also ich würde mich nicht als Scrum Master bewerben,
das nicht, aber warum sollte ich mich nicht bei einer Firma bewerben, die auch einen
Scrum Master sucht? Blocker, ja, wusste, wusste, es geht bei uns nicht anders. Ich
meine, hallo, wer macht denn bitteschön Meetings um 17 Uhr und dann am besten noch zwei Stunden
oder so? Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist. Leute, jetzt kommen wir mal
zur Hauptattraktion des heutigen Streams. Ich würde das gar nicht lange warten lassen,
weil es könnte sein, dass es ein relativ kurzer Stream wird, wenn das nämlich nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe die letzte ihrer Art gefunden, Leute. Die CoGeek Steckdosenleiste nur rebrandet.
Das ist die CoGeek Steckdosenleiste. Guckt, seht ihr da? Das ist die hier. Schaut her.
Ich muss gucken, das ist die gleiche. Ich muss gucken, dass ich den Switch nicht wieder
rausziehe. Das ist die und das ist angeblich die letzte Steckdosenleiste, die es gibt auf
Amazon. Der letzte Typ Steckdosenleiste, den es gibt auf Amazon, der flashbar ist. Mehr
gibt es nicht mehr. Ihr könnt durchgucken, ihr werdet nichts finden. Ihr findet vielleicht
nur normale Steckdosen mit Glück, aber welche, die so alte Firmware haben oder überhaupt
gar kein ESP866 mehr, sind mittlerweile die Regel. Dass du noch eine findest mit ESP866
und alte Firmware, dass du die OTA flashen kannst, ist selten. Das ist vom Aussterben
bedroht. Das ist die letzte ihrer Art. Ich hoffe, es funktioniert auch. Laut Amazon-Bewertung
funktioniert es noch. Ihr seht, ich habe es noch nicht aufgehabt. Das ist noch original
zu hier. Also kein Fake. Also entweder klappt es jetzt. Können wir ein bisschen gucken
oder es klappt nicht und dann haben wir gelitten. Wenn du eine flashbare Steckdosenleiste entwickelst,
bin ich der Erste, der Sellout macht dafür im Stream. Ich meine, an sich ist das ja nicht
kompliziert, was da an Technik drin ist. Das sind 5 Relays, ein Microcontroller und
halt ein halbwegs schönes Gehäuse. Fertig. Ich glaube, du kannst das nicht wirklich gut
vermarkten, weil du hast halt immer noch die ganzen China-Chinesen für 25 Euro. Da kommst
du wahrscheinlich nicht mit. Und den meisten Leuten ist es ja egal, ob man die flashen
kann oder nicht. Die machen das über diese hässliche Smartlife-App. Warum willst du
eine Steckdosenleiste flashen? Gute Frage. Die kommt jedes Mal. Erstens, hat mehrere
Gründe. Erstens, dann brauchst du nicht die offizielle App. Wenn du nicht die offizielle
App brauchst, dann brauchst du auch keine China-Chinesen-Cloud. Und das ist schon mal
eines der Hauptpunkte, dass die Chinesen rausbleiben. Dazu kommt, dass man das mit geflashter Firmware
auch deutlich besser an so ziemlich alles anschließen kann, was man will. Du hast irgendein
Heimautomatisierungssystem, was über MQTT geht, mit Custom-Firmware kein Problem. Mit
China-Chinesen-Firmware klappt das nicht. Willst schalten über ein Webinterface oder
über eine Web-AP mit Custom-Firmware kein Problem. Mit China-Hardware geht das nicht.
Das bedeutet auch, wenn dein Internet nicht funktioniert, kannst du deine Steckdosenleiste
nicht schalten mit China-Firmware. Geflasht, kein Problem. Gibt es sinnvolle Firmen, die
Open-Source-Smart-Home-Produkte anbieten? Die Shelley-Dinger sind nicht schlecht. Ich
glaube, die Shelley-Firmware ist nicht Open-Source, bin ich mir nicht sicher. Also die App auf
jeden Fall nicht. Aber die Firmware, keine Ahnung. Aber die Shelley-Firmware kannst du
ohne Probleme flaschen. Die lassen das von Haus aus zu. Es gibt bei Aliexpress-Hersteller,
die bieten Tasmota Pre-Flashed mittlerweile schon an. Bevor es losgeht, Leute, ich muss
mir noch mal schnell was zu trinken holen. Dann bin ich gleich am Start. Letztes Mal eine
Staubsäure geflasht. Ja, nice. Was hast denn du für einen? Ich kenne gar keine neuen
mehr, die man gescheit flaschen kann. Warte, ich hole mal schnell was zu trinken. Ich bin
in zwei Minuten wieder da.
Da bin ich wieder. Ich habe mir übrigens auch, falls es mal zu dunkel ist, weil ich hatte
letztens das Problem, wo ich was versucht habe zu flaschen, was daran zu lücken, wo
ich nichts gesehen habe. Ich habe mir jetzt hier auch mal so ein Licht noch hingelegt,
dass ich das noch mal extra hell machen kann. Dann sieht man besser was. Was braucht man
um diese Steckdosenleiste zu flaschen? Ja, das zeige ich dir jetzt gleich. Ich gucke
gleich. Sekunde. Muss ich erst mal wieder hinsetzen. Dann noch mal trinken abstellen.
Wenn es übel ist hochgesprintet, die Treppe, dass ich schnell wieder da bin. Guck mal,
das Cellyzeug ist anscheinend wirklich open source. Ein DreamBot Z10 Pro. Ah ja, 440
Euro mit Absaugstation ist wirklich günstig. Was heißt überhaupt flaschen? Die Firmware
austauschen so sinngemäß. Also, auf geht's. Ne, nicht so gut. Ich habe einen S5, den konnte
man gut flaschen. Die danach nicht mehr wirklich. Den S6 kann man glaube ich flaschen. Den muss
man mal komplett zerlegen, da hätte ich schon mal keinen Bock drauf. Und die danach ging
glaube ich gar nicht, bin ich mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher. Habe ich mich eben schon
darüber ausgelassen, muss ich jetzt nicht nochmal alles erzählen. Also, was man dafür
braucht, ganz einfach. Wir haben das ja schon noch vorbereitet alles. Also ich werde das
jetzt nicht alles nochmal neu installieren. Wir haben das ja schon vorbereitet für die
Steckdosen vom letzten Jahr. Also was man braucht ist eigentlich nur oder nicht zwingend
notwendig. Geht bestimmt auch anderweitig, aber praktischerweise ist man hat einen Raspberry
Pi. So, das hier ist jetzt ein 4er in diesem Fleer Case, was echt poggers ist. Ist aber
leider fast zu teuer oder halb so teuer wie der Raspberry Pi. So ein Aluminium Gehäuse,
das das dann schön die Wärme ableitet. Aber das ist wirklich gut. Man braucht ein Kappa
Pride Kabel, auch ganz wichtig. Und wir brauchen den Star der Alters Streams immer. Wir brauchen
unseren Small Access Point. Ohne den geht nichts. Nein, den brauchen wir nicht. Aber
man braucht natürlich einen W-Lan, dass man die Dinger später über das W-Lan teilen
kann. Also eigentlich brauchst du bloß einen Raspberry Pi und die passende Software drauf.
Wenn es denn geht. Wenn es nicht geht, ist das Stream wahrscheinlich relativ schnell
beendet. Also, fangen wir das mal an. Ich werde den Raspberry Pi erst mal kurz einstöpseln.
Dann Strom anmachen und dann gucken wir mal. Also ich habe hier hinten, was ihr gerade nicht
seht, hier hinten steht ein Switch. Guck, hier seht ihr noch die Ecke raus. Gucken vom
Switch. Da steht ein Mikro Tick. Mikro Tick Switch CSS 6108G2S Plus IN. Also zwei, man
sieht es hier unten, zwei SFP Plus Ports 10G und acht Gigabit Ports hat das Ding. Das
ist optimal hier für so meine Bastel, für meine Bastel Ecke. Da kann man alles anschließen,
was man so braucht. So, schließen wir den Raspberry Pi erstmal an. Ich glaube ich habe
irgendwo Kabels dafür. Übrigens auch so ein Ding. China-Chinesen-Kabel. Ich habe hier
von den Kabeln. Gibt es in unterschiedlichen Farben. Ich habe von diesen USB-Kabeln 50er
Pack bei Aliexpress gekauft. Das ist ungefähr einen Meter lang. Hat USB-C, Mikro-USB in
einem und hat weniger als ein Euro das USB-Kabel gekostet. Ich glaube 85 Cent umgerechnet das
USB-Kabel. Also China kaufen, finde ich lohnt sich schon, wenn man die richtigen Sachen
holt. Ich meine, jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, vollkommen zurecht, wozu braucht man
50 USB-Kabel? Aber die Antwort ist ganz einfach. Es ist besser, man hat 50 USB-Kabel als man
braucht 50 USB-Kabel. So, wenn man das jetzt verstehen konnte, wie ich das meine. Ne, weiter
verkaufen nicht. Gibt es einen Link zu dem Kabel? Ich glaube, die gibt es in der Form
nicht mehr. Das ist schon ein Jahr her, wo ich die gekauft habe. Ne, also ich habe nie
wieder USB-Kabel-Probleme. Ich mache bald Wish-Champ mache ich auf. Da kann man direkt
dropshippen. Da kann man sich auf Knopfdruck seinen Dropshipping-Shop erstellen. Der Wish-Champ.
So, machen wir mal den Raspberry Pi an. Ich kann es mir immer nicht merken, was ist Strom,
hinten oder vorne? Ach ne, gibt es ja mittlerweile nur noch einen. So, der Raspberry Pi ist an,
hier guck da, es bootet. Jetzt müssen wir uns mal drauf einloggen und gucken, ob alles
läuft. Zack, Firefox aufmachen. Frage? Echt? Wo? Wish-Champ ist schon weg? Was? Wie,
Wish-Champ, was soll das? Gebated. Ne, ich würde das auch garantiert nicht Wish-Champ
nennen. Wenn ich das nämlich Wish-Champ nenne, dann verklagt mich Wish wahrscheinlich. Okay,
Mini-USB ist tatsächlich selten. Es gibt nur noch genau ein Gerät, das Mini-USB hat,
das ist mein Mikrofon. So, also Pi, et, tja, ist es der? Hey, sicher, dass es der ist? Hm,
der wird es wahrscheinlich sein. Kann man sich, kann man irgendwie checken, ob das ein
Raspberry Pi 4 ist? Gibt es irgendwas für die Pi-Info oder sowas? Check, if Pi ist 4.
Gibt es irgendwie sowas? Ah, guck mal hier. Aha! Bam! Stack Overflow, einfach Beste.
In dem Fall war es sogar Stack Exchange. Stack Overflow. Ich sag's ja immer wieder. Man muss
die Sache nicht wissen, man muss einfach nur wissen, was man suchen muss. Was, in Hardtop
steht das drin? Ach, du meinst Anzahl der Kerne oder, ne, hä? Wie soll man das in Hardtop
erkennen? Wie soll ich in Hardtop jetzt erkennen, ob das ein Pi 4 ist? Das muss man jetzt erklären.
Jaja, Uptime, ganz genau. Uptime ist eindeutig, da erkenne ich sofort, ob es ein Raspberry
Pi 4 ist. Ach, du meinst über die, ja gut, stimmt, das könnte ich auch gucken. Wir haben
4 Gigabyte, das muss ein Raspberry Pi 4 sein, das stimmt. Aber mal im Ernst, das ist doch
die deutlich schönere Variante hier, oder? Der sagt's dir ja direkt. So, wo haben wir
denn unser, wo haben wir denn unser, ähm, haben wir hier überhaupt das Repo schon drauf
ausgecheckt? Ja, hier ist Tuya Convert. Genau, also wir brauchen einen Raspberry Pi und dann
muss man sich auf GitHub das hier auschecken. Habt ihr das mit, ne, hab ich da oben schon
gemacht, hier, guck da. Ne, ne. Du kannst jetzt vielleicht hieran, ne, aber selbst da
kannst du dir das nicht wirklich dran ableiten. Das musst du dir auschecken von GitHub und
damit kann man, äh, konnte man ziemlich viele China-Chinesen-Geräte flashen. Over the
Air, also sprich hier, einfach übers WLAN. Das Problem ist nur, die meisten China-Geräte
gehen nicht mehr. Ja, das sagt. Gut, dann probieren wir das mal aus. Achso, ich muss
den Access-Point noch kurz starten. Super, super schmoll Access-Point. Äh, MikroTik,
wo ist er denn hier, da. Muss ich mal kurz, kurz einschalten, weil wir brauchen ja einen
Access-Point, wo wir das dann anmelden, wenn Custom Firmware drauf ist. Der wird übrigens
per, jetzt mal kurz weg, der wird übrigens per Mikro-USB versorgt. Ich kann es nicht
oft genug sagen, der Access-Point ist mega nice für so, für so Bastelgeschichten. Das
ist ein Access-Point mit vollwertigem Router-OS drauf, für, also MikroTik-Router-OS für
25 Euro. Kann zwar nur 2,4 Gigahertz, aber für so Bastelkram ist das optimal, das Teil.
So, der sollte jetzt starten. Ich weiß nicht, ob man die Lichter sieht, dass der da, dass
der an ist. Er ist sicherlich genug. Ich glaube, das erkennt man nicht. Äh, auch PoE. Ich
glaub auch PoE, ja. Ich glaub auch PoE. Ja. Allerdings, ähm, der Switch kann kein PoE,
deswegen kann ich da kein PoE machen. Ja, also der ist richtig, der ist richtig pock.
Das ist jetzt kein Access-Point, wo ich mein Haus mit versorgen würde oder so, aber für
so Basteldinger ist das wirklich massive nice. So, irgendwann sollte eigentlich der Access-Point
an Start kommen. Root, Add. Ah, Moment. Es ist 137, nicht 127, kann das sein? Lull. Ja,
es ist auch das Richtige. 137 ist es. Na gut. Alles klar. So, Access-Point ist da. IP, DHCP-Server,
Leases. So, hier ist, guck mal, hier ist das alte TAS Motorzeuger. Das ist Chibate. Der
ist garantiert nicht an. Der alte Debon-Mini. Den hab ich gegrillt. Der kann definitiv nicht
mehr an sein. Das expired und wird sich auch nie wieder was abholen. So, hier taucht dann
unsere custom-geflechte Steckdosenleiste im DHCP-Server auf. Kommen wir gucken, was für
eine IP gekriegt hat. Aber jetzt gehen wir mal auf unseren Raspberry Pi. Ne, vorher,
wir packen erstmal die Steckdosenleiste aus, würde ich sagen. Hast du die ganzen IOT-Geräte
in einem Subnetz oder so drinne? Zum größten Teil. Also, ich hab zwei WLANs. Ich hab einen
China-Chinesen-IOT-WLAN. Auch mit Client-Isolation. Isolierung. Abgeschottet, also sprich, dass
die Clients nicht miteinander reden können. In einem extra WLAN drinne, wo auch kein
Internetzugriff erlaubt ist und ich glaube Firewall-Technisch ist das einzige, was erlaubt
ist NTP auf den Router und MQTT zu einem Proker. Ansonsten ist nichts erlaubt im China-IOT-WLAN.
Dann hab ich auch ein normales WLAN für Handy, Tablets und sonst was. Noch einen Bastel-WLAN
für Sachen wie hier. Und ein internes Netz und... jo. Das war's im Großen und Ganzen.
Das ist natürlich blöd, Helmo. Da fällt mir eigentlich bloß ein, WLAN-Geräte näher zusammenrücken.
Man kann ja beispielsweise das eine WLAN-Gerät direkt an die eine Wand und das dann auf der
anderen Seite direkt an die andere Wand und von dort dann weiter per Kabel oder so. Aber
ansonsten. Oftmals ist halt auch was die Leute dann haben, so richtig alter Schrott. Z-C-H-R-I-E-S-R-I.
Danke für den Zap. Wenn ihr jetzt noch ein Essen nehmt, dann wisst ihr euch, dass es
Chris heißen soll. Aber ist ja nicht. Ja, würde ich auch so machen. Also unabhängig
davon ob es China-Chinesen-Zeug ist. Das bietet sich einfach an. Was ich ja geil finden würde,
wenn irgendjemand mal WPA Enterprise baut, so dass die Geräte, dass die Clients es nicht
unterstützen müssen. Das ist ja WPA Enterprise, ist ja quasi der WLAN-Standard, wo man für
Authentifizierung einzelne User-Accounts anlegen kann. So kann man jedem Endgerät ein extra
User und Passwort geben. Das wäre unglaublich praktisch für ein IoT-Netzwerk. Weil dann
könnte man jedem Gerät eigenen Usernamen Passwort geben oder eigenes Passwort und könnte
das wegschmeißen und das Gerät einfach löschen. Und gut wärs. Aktuell muss man ja theoretisch
IoT-Geräte, um es mal übertrieben zu sagen, einschmelzen oder schreddern, bevor man sie
wegwirft, weil dein WLAN-Passwort halt überall steht, in den Geräten. Deswegen mach ich
es aktuell ganz einfach. Ich schmeiß IoT-Geräte einfach nicht weg. Ich hab einfach einen Sack
hier stehen, mit kaputten Controllern und alles und schmeiß das halt einfach nicht
weg. Irgendwann werd ich mir die einfach mal in die Tüte nehmen und schreddern lassen.
Okay, weiter gehts. Also es war und die Alternative ist, die Alternative ist ein WLAN-Passwort
in der Weltgeschichte verteilen. Cisco WLAN-Controller Compare Device Pass Phrases bei WPA2. Wirklich,
das ist cool. Und das ist dann aber auch kein WPA Enterprise. Das sieht dann für die Geräte
quasi so aus, wie normales Pre-Shared Key. Das ist ja das Wichtige. Das Small Access
Point, ja. Weil die ESPs können zwar theoretisch WPA Enterprise, aber nicht wirklich gut.
Die Cisco WLAN-Router, nee. Ease. Oh, das ist wieder Big Brain Cisco Kram. Big Brain
Cisco Stels. UniFi kann er bestimmt nicht, oder? Nee, die können das wahrscheinlich
nicht. Jaja, WPA Enterprise, das weiß ich. Das ist ja Schwachsinn. WPA Enterprise suckt.
Geht anscheinend nicht. Ja doch, das funktioniert. Das Problem ist dann, dass du ein bisschen
viele WLANs hast. Also ich kenne keinen WLAN Access Point, der 40 SSIDs aufmachen kann.
Und außerdem ist das auch WLAN technisch nicht so sinnvoll, 40, also Funk technisch
nicht so sinnvoll. Ja, das ist, also theoretisch kannst du Multi SSID machen, aber mehr als
3, 4 würde ich da nicht aufmachen. Ich glaube, die UniFi Access Points können auch maximal
nur 4 SSIDs. Okay, aber ich packe jetzt erstmal die Steckdosenleiste aus. Also wir gucken
mal, ob das wirklich die original Krogi Steckdosenleiste ist, nur unter Hammer Rebranding. So, gucken
wir mal. Also da hier aufmachen. Wo habe ich denn meinen? Ah, der Keks muss im Bild bleiben,
so geht das ja nicht. So, legen wir den Raspberry Pi mal kurz hin, machen den Kram mal auf.
Die andere Seite. So, und jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das passt. Mods haben die Commands
gepimpt. Ja, ein bisschen. So, also schauen wir mal rein. Hier, das haben wir hier. Hammer,
das hat Hammer da gemacht. Also es ist schon mal besser verpackt als die Krogi Steckdosenleiste,
hatte ich den Eindruck. Als hätten sie da irgendwas gemacht. Aber ich glaube, es ist
trotzdem die gleiche Steckdosenleiste. Es ist exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste. Das
stimmt mich zuversichtlich. Es ist wirklich exakt die gleiche Steckdosenleiste. Einfach
China Rebrand. Ist Hammer nicht irgendwie so ein Hardware-Ding aus Bayern? Es ist die
Krogi Steckdosenleiste, hier Leute, guckt mal. Es ist die gleiche. Exzellent, exzellent.
Nur, hier unten steht Krogi und hier steht gar nichts. Guck mal, Hammer hat noch nicht
mal richtig reprinten lassen. Normalerweise würde hier unten der Hersteller stehen, aber
nope. Hammer. So, mal hier aufmachen. Und dann probieren wir das Ganze mal aus. Das Hammer
hat nur reprandedes Zeug. Ist mir egal in dem Fall, solange das flashbar ist. Also wenn
das flashbar ist, kaufe ich mir noch 10 Stück. Also ohne Mist, man braucht Steckdosenleisten
braucht man immer. Und ich habe 3 Stück, die geflasht sind, aber die habe ich schon alle
im Einsatz. Und man kann einfach nicht genug Steckdosenleisten haben. Und es gibt immer
weniger, die sich flashen lassen. Ich kaufe mir, wie gesagt, wenn das wirklich flashbar
ist, kaufe ich mir gleich noch 10 Stück. Easy. Gut, also Steckdosenleiste am Start.
Packen wir mal hier raus. Noch nicht gleich anschließen, Leute, weil es kann sein, dass
die Dinger instant in den pairing-Modus gehen. Das will man nicht. Und im Zweifelsfall muss
man sie ausstecken und wieder anstecken. Ja, das geht auch. Man will die erst im pairing-Modus
haben, wenn man seinen Raspberry Pi anhat. Mir fällt gerade auf, das ist blöd, wie ich
das mache. Ich muss das hier mal schließen. Firefox und hier aufmachen. Dann in Window-Modus
schalten. Controls ausblenden. Sticky machen. Ah, so ist das doch gut. Jetzt kann man nämlich
den Raspberry Pi sich angucken. Und wir haben noch nebenbei die Steckdosenleiste. Oh, slacked.
Massive-Lack, Alter. Poggers-Lack. Weniger Poggers-Lack. Paints-Champ-Lack. Na, jetzt
geht's. Ja, ja, ist okay. Alles klar. Sind die einzelnen Dosen in der Leiste schaltbar?
Ja. Deswegen, das ist ja das Geile da dran. Das ist quasi eine IP-Steckdosenleiste für
30 oder 35 Euro. Richtiges Picture-in-Picture ist aber doof. Das kann man nicht resize-en.
Das hier kann man resize-en. So. Also, gehen wir hier rein. Oh, ich brauche eine Tablet.
Ich muss mal ins Bart mal ein iPad holen. Also, wunderbar. Weil man muss immer, wenn
man das startet, ein Tablet in das WLAN packen. iPad als Klo-Zeitung. Ja. Ich habe das oft
im Bart liegen tagsüber. Wenn ich aufs Klo gehe, kann ich dort Browser aufmachen oder
YouTube aufmachen oder irgendwas. Bin ja mittlerweile schon so medienabhängig, ich kann nicht mal
kacken ohne YouTube zu gucken. Weiß ich, hat einer noch das Problem? Ich konnte, also
jetzt mal ohne Mist, ne? Ich konnte früher mich abends ins Bett legen, habe die Augen
zugemacht, Bett ge- und habe einfach gepennt. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Ich muss jetzt
ins Bett und dann entweder auf dem Tablet oder auf dem Handy noch irgendeinen Stream anmachen.
Und ich penne allein, wenn der Stream läuft. Das ist kein Problem. Ich kann aber nicht
mal schlafen ohne Handy oder Tablet. Richtig hängen geblieben. Ohne Mist, ich bin früher
ins Bett. Ich meine, wie gesagt, ich bin 1984 geboren. Ich habe alles mitbekommen. Ich habe
quasi die Pre-, also ich habe noch so richtig vor Mainstream PC mitbekommen, vor Mainstream
Internet. Dann habe ich Mainstream PC, Mainstream Internet, vor Smartphone und nach Smartphone.
Also ich habe quasi so mehr oder weniger alle wichtigen Technologieabschnitte so mitgemacht
noch. Und ich konnte mich wirklich früher einfach ins Bett legen, habe gesagt, okay,
ich mache jetzt Augen zu. Dann fängt man an, sich irgendwie über komische Dinge noch
nachzudenken oder so. Und dann schläft man ein. Und mittlerweile kann ich nicht mehr pennen
ohne Handy am Start. So, also, was man jetzt machen muss ist, sich dieses Repo hier klonen,
was ich schon gemacht habe. Also wie gesagt, hier das da. Nee, nee, tu ja Convert, klonen.
Das klont man sich. Das haben wir gemacht. Das ist gar kein Ding. Und dann geht man einfach
da rein und sagt Start, Start, Flash. So, dann fragt er mich, ob ich noch irgendwelche
Dinger stoppen will. Ja, will ich. Ja, ist okay. Yes. So. Und dann sagt er mir, ich muss
jetzt ein Gerät, was nicht die Steckdosenleiste ist, ins WLAN packen. Sonst funktioniert
das Ganze nicht. Ihr guckt. This step is important. Blah, blah, blah. Connect any other device
to the Wi-Fi. We trust Flash. Das heißt auch wirklich so. We trust Flash. Das mache ich
jetzt mal ohne, dass ihr das sehen könnt, weil. Will die WLANs hier nicht leaken? WLANs.
We trust Flash. Warum hast du kein ESP als Dummiklein? Das ist eine gute Idee. War gar
nicht dran gedacht. So, dann sieht das so aus mit dem iPhone. Guckt mit dem iPad. Guckt
hier. Connected. Connected. We trust. Das müsst ihr eigentlich gar nichts machen. Einfach
nur einfach nur eingeloggt lassen. So. Put your IoT device in Autokonfig. Das machen
wir jetzt. Müssen wir noch mal gucken, wie wir das in Autokonfig kriegen. Oftmals ist
es so, es reicht. Wenn man das einfach einschaltet, dann gehen die automatisch in Autokonfig.
Und wenn nicht, dann muss man den Knopf einfach ein paar Sekunden halten. Meistens zumindest.
So. Macht das was? Es schaltet sich an und aus. Okay, da muss ich es wahrscheinlich
einfach gedrückt halten. Also Ziel sollte sein, man erkennt es nicht richtig, dass das
Grün blinkt. Das ist so, man erkennt das gar nicht richtig. Okay, es blinkt. Es blinkt.
Huh? Bosschamp? Bosschamp? Muss ich den Stecker nicht rausziehen?
Es macht noch überhaupt nichts. Ich fürchte, die Firmware ist zu neu. Ich fürchte, die
Firmware ist zu neu, weil der blinkt nicht mehr. Ich glaube, die Firmware ist zu neu.
Scheiße. Mach einfach mal an und aus. Ja, kann ich gleich machen. Wir können das kaputt
geht es nicht. Kaputt geht es nicht. War bei mir auch so komisch. Okay, ich mach das mal.
Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert. Ich lasse den erstmal machen. Er hat geplinkt. Aha,
es funktioniert. Doch. Die ist noch flashbar. Okay, Zehner Bestellung ist raus. Zehner Bestellung
ist direkt raus. Flash, Tasmota. Jetzt muss man auswählen, was man flashen will. Wir wollen
natürlich Tasmota flashen. Sind wir Schnur, dass wir flashen wollen? Ja, wollen wir Tasmota
flashen? Erstmal 300 Euro investiert. Stimmt eigentlich. Richtig viel Kohle. No. Gut,
und jetzt gehen wir in die WLAN-Settings und verbinden uns mit der Steckdose. Tasmota.
Ja. So, jetzt sind wir mit der Steckdose verbunden. Ich zeig's euch gleich. Guck hier. Dann lockt
man sich, die Steckdose macht dann, ich mach mal groß, die Steckdose macht dann ein Access
Point auf. Und da verbindet man sich drauf. Ich sollte vielleicht mal den Paus-Champ wegmachen,
das Emote ist ein bisschen zu Pain's Champ. Ja, dann lockt man sich ein auf dem Access
Point von der Steckdosenleiste und gibt dann sein Access Point-Gedöns ein, was man haben
will. Das mach ich jetzt mal kurz. Ohne, ohne dass ich euch zugucken lasse. Omi, ich hab
mich vertippt, fuck. Das ist übrigens, da muss man aufpassen, wenn man sich vertippt.
Je nach Device kann's sein, dass man es nicht mehr zurücksetzen kann. Okay. Passwort gespeichert,
es restartet sich und jetzt gucken wir auf unseren Access Point, ob's auftaucht. Access
Point. Das sieht gut aus, guck mal da. Bäm. Da ist sie. Da ist sie, unsere Steckdosenleiste.
Die Steckdose ist jetzt noch nicht richtig eingestellt. Aktuell sieht es so aus, als
wäre das nur ein, als wäre das nur ein, ein Schalter. Das ist ja falsch. Das müssen
fünf Schalter sein. Das sind fünf Schalter, weil, Moment. Hier ist das iPad weg. Es sind
ja fünf Schalter, weil 1, 2, 3, 4 und USB. Und USB sind fünf Schalter. Das heißt wir
brauchen jetzt noch das passende Template dafür. So und damit wir das jetzt auch richtig
schön, damit wir das jetzt richtig schön machen können, schalte ich jetzt erstmal
meine Home Assistant VM ein. Da können wir das richtig mal einrichten, so wie man das
machen würde. Home Assistant VM einschalten. Nur mal so exemplarisch jetzt. Also das erste,
was wir hier jetzt machen, ist erstmal uns ein richtiges Template raussuchen. Ich schiebe
das mal kurz ein bisschen weiter weg. Also wir brauchen ein Template dafür. Da gibt
es so eine, da gibt es eine schöne Seite, Pontus Motor. Da kann, wie packt man HA in
eine VM? Einfach das offizielle VM-Template nehmen. Es gibt so eine, es gibt so eine schöne
Seite. Da haben ja Community Leute Geräte zusammengetragen, die es so gibt. Und in
dem Fall ist ESP Home aber doof. Du willst ja nichts selbst machen, du willst einfach
fix und fertig haben. So, guck mal unter Plugs und Sensors, ob es da einen Hammer gibt. Oh,
das sieht schon mal gut aus. Hammer. Hammer. Da war es doch, guck mal. Hammer. PRC4USBpowerstrip,
hier ist das Template. Gut. Gehen wir hier hin. Configuration. Config Template. Äh nicht
stimmt überhaupt nicht. Config Other. Und dann schmeißen wir das Template hier rein.
Sagen Activate und Save. Dann Restartet es neu und wenn es jetzt Restartet ist, dann
blinkt es vielleicht. Müssen wir mal gucken. Und jetzt seht ihr. Äh was ist denn das? Sollte
das nicht eigentlich. Es sollte eigentlich 4 Knöpfe haben. Es hat irgendwie rumgepackt.
Sonst hat man 4 Knöpfe. Guckt. Na super, man erkennt das jetzt hier nicht. Ach guck mal,
das ist. Das Gehäuse von dieser Hammerleiste ist mega fail. Du hast hier normalerweise
ein Licht daneben. Ich weiß gar nicht ob man das überhaupt erkennt. Da wo mein Mauszeige
ist, ist ungefähr ein Licht normalerweise. Das erkennt man überhaupt nicht. Also das
Licht kommt da nicht richtig durch. Ich mach mal kurz die Lampe aus, dann erkennt man es
vielleicht besser. Die USB Socket sind auch schaltbar, aber nur alle zusammen, nicht
einzeln. Das wäre zu geil, wenn das einzeln schaltbar wäre. Ja jetzt erkennt man es. Guckt.
Seht ihr. Das ist relativ schnell. Es ist nur ein minimaler Lack. Also. Da kannst du dich
echt nicht beschweren. Das ist mehr oder weniger so realtime. Komm mal kurz hier hin. Guckt
USB kann ich auch schalten. Ach so ja, ob ich USB schalten kann, das kann ich sehen.
Das seht ihr jetzt ja so gar nicht. Das müsste ich, ja wenn ich wüsste wo ich das Teil hin
habe. Ich hab doch so ein USB. So ein PogChamp USB Tester. Da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher
wo ich den hingeschmissen hab. Kann man nämlich testen, was, ob die USB Anschlüsse richtig
funktionieren. Ok den hab ich irgendwo hier reingeschmissen. Ich hab legit keine Ahnung
mehr wohin. Ach hier ist er. Guckt mal. So jetzt ist USB aus. Jetzt machen wir das Ding
hier mal rein. Müsste man jetzt eigentlich sehen. So. Jetzt machen wir USB mal an. Jetzt
haben wir hier. Ups. Jetzt haben wir hier 5,16 Volt am USB Anschluss. Nice. Ja dann sieht
man also das Schalten funktioniert wirklich. Kann man sich eigentlich nicht beschweren.
Machen wir wieder aus. Zack. USB braucht man schon ein bisschen bis es ausgeht. Das liegt
aber an den Geräten weil die nicht so viel verbrauchen. So jetzt mach ich mal das Licht
wieder an. Was? Ich glaube ich hab an meinem Keylight gewackelt. Das geht jetzt nicht mehr
an. Ringlight. Das ist schlecht. Zack. Hab ich den da jetzt gemacht. Ringlight. Come
on. Lass dich nicht so bitten. Geh einfach wieder an. Schauen wir mal. Geht hoffentlich
gleich wieder. So. So bis das Ringlight sich jetzt einkriegt. Achso wir können ein Firmware
Update machen gerade. Ja. Wir können noch mal schnell ein Firmware Update machen weil
es gibt ja ein neues TASMOTA. Aber ihr seht es funktioniert alles. Und das ist halt echt
nice. Sowas gibt es normalerweise nur für deutlich mehr Geld als IP Steckdosen leisten
oder eben halt als China Dinger wo man selbst keine Kontrolle mehr drüber hat. Das ist
halt wirklich richtig nice. Dass man da noch was Flashbares gefunden hat. Ich gehe mal
davon aus das Hammer einfach die uralten Restbestände irgendwo gekauft hat und da waren halt noch
alte Flashbare dabei. Wie lang ist das Kabel? 2 Meter würde ich sagen. Ja 2 Meter. Ist die
Leiste schon kaputt? Nee funktioniert alles. Guck kann man alles schalten. Ich warte jetzt
bis mein Ringlight wieder funktioniert. Das sollte sich jetzt eigentlich mal wieder einkriegen
bald. Hoffentlich mal. Oder auch nicht. Anscheinend nicht. Ist Hammer besser als die China Dinger?
Das sind China Dinger. Das ist ein reprandedes China Ding. Das ist exakt die gleiche China
Leiste die ich mir vor einem halben Jahr schon gekauft habe. Nur das Hammer das jetzt resellt.
Warum geht denn mein Keylight nicht an? Warum geht denn das Ringlight jetzt nicht an? Wo
ist denn das Problem? Musst du mich verarschen alter Lan? Warum geht das nicht an? Wallah!
Zeig mal her. Ich mach das mal raus. Was hat das Keylight denn für Probleme? Oh. Stopp.
Mal gucken ob es jetzt angeht. Ich hab das jetzt noch mal umgestapselt. Wenn ich müssen
mal kurz ohne. Ah Leute ich kann doch jetzt. Ah Big Brain Time. Ich hab doch jetzt hier
meine. So. Ist halt ein bisschen dumm. Der Winkel ist halt kacke mit dem Ding. Das ist
eigentlich wenn man irgendwo hinter der Heizung oder sowas schrauben muss. Ah Bassloss ist
wieder da. Geht nicht. Warum geht das Ringlight nicht an? Was ist denn das? Ich klicke auf
Ringlight starten und es geht nicht an. Habe ich das jetzt auch aus Versehen geflasht
oder was? Max hast du in deinem Leben das mal gebraucht? Tierzelle und zwischen Pflanzenzellen
unterscheiden? Äh klar täglich. Ah Ringlight geht wieder. Okay. Es ist wieder an und es
funktioniert wieder. Oh der Keks muss dahingucken sonst klappt das nicht. Exquisite. So. Jetzt
machen wir erstmal Firmware Update. Also. OTA. OTA TASMOTA. Releases. Aktuelle TASMOTA Version
ist 10. Ich weiß gar nicht ob das hier irgendwo steht. Aktuelle TASMOTA Bin runterladen. Safe.
Configuration. Ah ich kacke nur. Ich habe jetzt die Leiste ja rausgemacht. Lul. So.
Warten bis die Leiste wieder da ist. Jetzt ist die Leiste wieder da. Configuration. Firmware
Upgrade. Browse File. Downloads. Und ich weiß dass der erste mir jetzt sagt ich könnte
auch direkt die Urlangeben. Das funktioniert nicht weil ich nicht ins Internet komme. Wobei
doch von dem Access Point komme ich ins Internet. So. Firmware Update. Start. Erstmal seine,
erstmal den Reflink unter die Leute bringen hier. Hast du schon die Switche gesehen? Äh
nein. Wozu braucht man die? Was zeichnet die aus? So. Firmware Update funktioniert. Main
Menu. Ah. Main Menu. Version 10. Das ist die aktuelle. Hat alles funktioniert und schalten
geht immer noch. Exzellent. So. Jetzt werden wir das ganze nochmal in unsere Heimautomatisierung
einbinden. Das ist tatsächlich relativ easy. Wir gehen jetzt erstmal in unseren Home Assistant.
Ich schiebe das mal hier kurz runter weil die Kamera ist jetzt nicht so spektakulär.
Wir gehen jetzt in unseren Home Assistant. Das ist es. Jawoll. Da ist hier noch nichts
drinne. Da sind nur unsere Versuche vom letzten Mal drinne noch. Unser Test Home Assistant.
Gut. Und wir melden das. Dark Mode. Ja. Wir machen Dark Mode. Wir machen Dark Mode. Das
ist schon richtig. Wenn ich wüsste hier. Dark. Exzellent. Exzellent. Und Advanced Mode einschalten
haben wir schon. So. Das ist unser Home Assistant. Da können wir das jetzt ziemlich einfach
einbinden. Wir müssen auf unsere Steckdosenleiste gehen. Configuration. Also die IP raussuchen
vom Home Assistant. Das ist die hier. Dann geht man auf die Steckdosenleiste sagt. Konfigure
MQTT. Host. Rest stimmt. Rest kann man lassen. Passwort braucht man. User. User. Nehme ich
jetzt mal den Admin User. Das ist nicht die feine Art. Man macht normalerweise einen extra
User. Aber ich weiß, dass es funktioniert so. Save. Jetzt meldet sich die Steckdosenleiste
per MQTT am Home Assistant an. Und dann können wir mal in die Logs gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert
. Ach nee. Configuration. Supervisor. Addons. MQTT. Was ist denn da? Log. New Connection
from 2137. Ach doch. Ja klar. Das ist hier Connection von der Steckdosenleiste. Das wird
aus irgendwelchen Gründen genattet über den Router. Okay, war mir auch nicht klar, dass
das eingeschaltet ist. Aber meinetwegen. Alles klar. Steckdosenleiste verbunden. Und
das einzige, was wir jetzt noch machen müssen auf der Steckdosenleiste, ist in die Konsole
gehen und sagen Set Option. Und das bin ich mir aus dem Kopf nicht sicher. 61.0. Home
Assistant. Tasmota. Gucken wir mal. Set Option. Set Option 19.0 muss ich sagen. Das ist ein
bisschen kryptisch bei Tasmota. Wenn ich das gemacht habe. Jawoll. Wenn ich das gemacht
habe, sollte jetzt normalerweise in Home Assistant unter Configuration Integration Tasmota das
Gerät auftauchen. Und siehe da, der Hammer Strip ist da. Und wir haben es direkt in
Home Assistant drin. Was ich immer noch mag zum Einschalten ist die IP, dass ich sehen
kann im Home Assistant, was es hat. So und wir sehen, wir können jetzt das gleiche Ding
hier übers Web Interface. Können wir jetzt steuern über Moment. Über Home Assistant.
Man sieht es nicht richtig, aber es ist an. Man sieht es nicht richtig. Es funktioniert.
Es ist an. Wenn ich das alles ausmache, dann geht auch das USB aus. So und jetzt muss man
natürlich den Kram noch mal richtig benennen. Schauen wir mal was USB ist. Ist das hier
USB? Das ist USB. Dann würde ich das mal richtig benennen, weil Tasmota 5 ist relativ
nichts sagend. Dann würde ich das Ding jetzt, keine Ahnung, Hammer, USB, dass man das nachher
findet. Hier hat man auch die IP drin. Und den Rest würde ich halt irgendwie sinnvoll
benennen, dass man am Ende den Kram wieder findet. So und wenn man das in seinem Home
Assistant angelegt hat. So wenn man den Kram in seinem Home Assistant angelegt hat. Ach
so, die Entity ID kann man auch ändern. Man kann das Ding auch gleich oben Hammer nennen.
Was? MonkaS, no, no. Ich weiß nicht, was er will von mir. Ich bin in die Entity ID ein
bisschen. So und jetzt haben wir das da drin. Und wenn wir jetzt hier Dashboards haben, keine
Ahnung, Dashboards fürs Wohnzimmer, Dashboards für den Keller, wie auch immer. Hier haben
wir ein bisschen ausprobiert. Jetzt stellen wir mal vor, wir hätten hier die Steckdosenleiste
im Keller liegen zum Beispiel, um da irgendwelche Sachen an- und auszuschalten. Da könnten
wir jetzt einfach im Dashboard hier uns den Kram hinzufügen. Wobei das natürlich ein
bisschen hässlich ist, so groß. Ich würde eher sagen, wir nehmen sowas hier, wir nehmen
hier sowas wie den, äh, das Grid. Sagen drei Columns und sagen hier Buttons zufügen. Hammer
1, Hammer 1, Hammer 1. Stellen wir das jetzt noch um. Guck und jetzt ist wichtig, dass
man den Kram richtig benannt hat. Weil jetzt kann ich hier nämlich direkt nach dem Namen
suchen und nicht nach diesen kryptischen Dingern. Weil wenn ich jetzt drei Tasmotageräte habe,
ist es natürlich sehr undurchsichtig, was es eigentlich ist und so ist es besser. USB,
save. Und schon habe ich meine Steckdosenleiste in meinem Dashboard fürs Wohnzimmer oder für
den Keller drin und kann hier einschalten und ausschalten. Und das ist jetzt halt auch
in UI was relativ touchfreundlich ist. Guckt, USB ist jetzt aus. Ihr seht, es ist ausgegangen
oder geht gleich aus. Fahre ich es an, geht es bitte an. Ja. Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch
jetzt. Natürlich kann man die Dinger dann auch am Endeffekt so benennen, wie man es
braucht. Also Hammer 1 und so ist jetzt interne Bezeichnung ganz gut, aber realistisch betrachtet
würde das dann sowas heißen wie Fernseh. Das nächste ist dann keine Ahnung Sound. Was
weiß ich, was hat man da sonst noch? Blu-ray? Keine Ahnung, PS5 und Shitbox. Und USB. Hätte
man dann sowas. Dann könnte man das quasi übers Dashboard im Wohnzimmer ein und ausschalten.
Und das alles nur dank Big Brain Custom Firmware. Nice. Ja, also nachdem das mit dem Flaschen
gut funktioniert hat. Das war diese Steckdosenleiste hier. Gucken. Sag mal, ist die teurer geworden
oder hat die das letzte Mal auch schon 36 Euro gekostet? Zack, Amazon. Ich muss Amazon
auf dem iPad aufmachen und gucken. Amazon. Wie? Ich hab da kein Amazon drauf? Lul. Warum
hab ich keine Amazon App auf meinem Tablet? Monka. Super, da bin ich jetzt nicht mal eingeloggt.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht gucken. Apps sind bloated. Auf dem Handy kann ich jetzt auch
nicht gucken, weil das Handy, das Handy habe ich ja gerade für die Kamera hier oben im
Einsatz. Ich hab wirklich die Amazon App nicht drauf gehabt. Wahrscheinlich verwende
ich die immer auf dem Handy. Weiß nicht. Hätte nie gedacht, dass Max ein iPad. Warum
nicht? Jetzt muss ich mal, jetzt muss ich mal den Flex raushängen. Ich glaube, ich hab
mittlerweile 15 Tablets. Nicht Tablets. 15 Smartphones, Schrägschräg Tablets, die sich
über die letzten Jahre so angesammelt haben. Drei Viertel sind da von Android. Der Rest,
ja, ne, ne, ne. 60, 60% sind Android, 40% ist iOS. Also ich hab genug von beidem. Und
das meiste davon habe ich mir noch nicht mal gekauft. Ich hab eine gesponserte Shield TV
noch. Tablet, Shield Tablet oder wie das Ding hieß. Dann von G2A habe ich mal eins gekriegt.
Android, Android Gerät. Dann haben wir zwei iPads. iPhone 11, iPhone SE. HD 10 von Amazon,
zwei Stück in HD 8. Ein ganz altes Tegra Note. Ich glaub, das war's. Ach ne und auch so ein
komisches Asus. Ja, die Edelmetalle liegen bei mir rum in Form von Tablets. Spielst du
noch GTA RP? Was heißt denn, spielst du noch GTA RP? Ich glaube, du lext critical information.
Ich habe aber noch nie GTA RP gespielt. Also, ähm, was frage? Wo denn? Wie heißt der Cloudflare
Service, womit du Subdomains und so einrichtest, wenn ich das richtige Erinnerung habe. Äh,
das ist da ganz normale Cloudflare DNS. Musst du es aber nicht über Cloudflare machen. Du
kannst es über fast jeden anderen DNS machen. Ich mache das über Cloudflare, weil mein
Domain Registratus sackt und keine DNS API hat. Arbeit dir für CI, CD, POG Zeug mit
Jenkins auf der App. Wir haben mehrere Jenkins, ja. Aber ehrlich gesagt ist es immer weniger
geworden, was auf Jenkins raufläuft. Ich persönlich mag Jenkins. Weiß gar nicht, hat jemand einen
Haare, warum Jenkins in den letzten Jahren so den guten Ruf verloren hat? Weiß gar nicht
warum. Ich mag Jenkins eigentlich, weil es eben schön flexibel ist und das super verbiegen
kann für alles Mögliche. Ähm, klar, sag mal mal, wenn du auf GitHub bist, dann stehen
die Leute halt alle unglaublich auf GitHub Actions. Haben wir hier im Stream auch schon
gemacht. Jenkins hat noch keinen Yammel. Hä, wie? Die Drehpost kannst du schon ewig auschecken
mit Jenkins und was du dann damit auswertest, ist ja dein Ding. Das stimmt, Jenkins ist
nicht Cloud-Native, wobei man heutzutage Container technisch auch alles in der Cloud laufen lassen
kann, was man will. Ja, ich verstehe es, wenn man es übers Repo konfigurieren will. Ach,
das meinst du, dass im Repo so eine Bild-Yammel oder so reinkommt? Ja, das geht glaube ich
nicht. Ja, ja, ja, das glaube ich, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe schon mich in der Richtung
schon eine Weile nicht mehr mit Jenkins beschäftigt. Ich glaube, das geht noch nicht, ja. Aber
ich mag Jenkins. Ach so, das meinst du mit Cloudflare. Nee, dann brauchst du die kostenlose,
also die kostet erstmal nichts, die Cloudflare DDoS Protection brauchst du dann. Dann musst
du den Cloudflare einstellen, wohin der das proxen soll und dann dein DNS auf Cloudflare
umschalten. Also der DNS löst auf Cloudflare auf und Cloudflare schiebt dann Port 443
quasi weiter. Ja, das geht, das funktioniert. Ja, also um das zu beantworten, wir haben
auf der Arbeit ein paar Jenkins, das ist aber immer weniger geworden. Also was bei uns jetzt,
ich weiß gar nicht, worauf unsere ganzen Entwickler stehen. Also ich werde in Zukunft auch auf
der Arbeit mehr GitHub Actions verwenden, einfach weil wir immer mehr Sachen in GitHub packen
und ansonsten keine Ahnung, was die anderen treiben. Jenkins kann das auch, ja, ich weiß,
ich glaube Jenkins ist einfach nicht mehr cool genug. Ich meine Jenkins hat ein richtig
mieses Logo. Das sieht aus wie 2005, guckt euch das mal an. Ich meine, wer will das Software
mit so einem Logo verwenden? Das ist so richtig exquisite Logo. Drones, das habe ich mittlerweile
auch schon öfters gehört, ja. Was? Das habe ich nicht kapiert, was? Ich hatte so 2006
mal auf einem Windows XP Laptop ein Programm, das wenn man mit einem WLAN Netz verbunden war,
einen Key ausgelesen hat und mit dem konnte man sich dann auch mit anmelden, wenn das Passwort
geändert wurde. Was? Also das wäre fatal, wenn du dich noch einloggen könntest, wenn
das Passwort geändert wurde. Meinst du vielleicht, dass gar nicht das WLAN Passwort, sondern
dass es irgendwie so ein Portal davor war, wo du dich anmelden musstest, wo dann ein
Browser aufgegangen ist? Das hat ja mit dem WLAN Passwort aber nichts zu tun. Das geht
erst, wenn du im WLAN dann schon drin bist. Ansonsten wäre es ja fatal, wenn du das WLAN
Passwort änderst und irgendwelche Leute, die Special Hacker mit Windows XP am Start haben,
sich einfach so noch verbinden könnten. Ne, ne, ne, das effektive WLAN Passwort, ne, das
WLAN Passwort gibt es nicht. Vielleicht war das noch für WEP, weil es war 2006, vielleicht
war das irgendein WEP Cracker oder so. Den musst du dann aber jedes Mal neu laufen lassen.
Kannst du die Customfirma nochmal überfliegen? Ja, was genau? Hier, da. Was willst du sehen?
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dich interessiert nicht der Home Assistant Teil, sondern hier
die Konfig für die Customfirma. Abgesehen davon, dass die nur 10 Ampere kann, hat das
eigentlich gar nicht... naja, das reicht doch. Es sei denn, du willst Heizlüfter ein paar
dran anschließen. Für was reicht denn das net? Für die meisten Geräte, die du da anschließen
kannst, das ist doch mehr als genug. Ich mein, guck mal, was habe ich hier dran angeschlossen?
Lass mal gucken. An der einen Leiste habe ich hier mein Ringlight angeschlossen und die
anderen Sachen zum Basteln. Hier im Keller habe ich einen Raspberry Pi angeschlossen,
das für die Türgegengesprecherlage deckt, Zeugs angeschlossen, den Schalter für die
Pumpe angeschlossen, also nix, was irgendwie großartig da Leistung braucht. Wenn du da
jetzt irgendwie vier Heizlüfter dran anschließen willst, mit jeweils, keine Ahnung, 2000 Watt,
ja da würde ich mir das nochmal überlegen. Du willst, du vertraust dem nicht ohne Prüfzeichen.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Also die haben immerhin schon mal ein CE-Zeichen
aufgedruckt und außerdem wird das von einer deutschen Firma vertrieben, die sind dann
am Arsch, wenn die sowas hier verkaufen. Ansonsten hast du nix. Das kann sich eh jeder
nachdrucken, ist egal. Na GS müsste da nicht drauf kriegen. Das Ding prüft keiner, geschweige
dann. Also ich würde mir da jetzt nicht so viel Gedanken machen. Wie gesagt, zumal es
auch noch von einer deutschen Firma vertrieben wird, also im Zweifelsfall sind die dann im
Zweifelsfall. Bei der Prüfung explodiert es wahrscheinlich. Wir machen größtens als
damit einfache SQL, Backup, Jobs und PowerShell Befehl absetzen. Ja, finde ich das auch eine
gute Sache. Jobrunner Geschichten, ja. Deswegen mag ich Jenkins. Jenkins ist da halt richtig,
Jenkins ist nicht nur Software, Code technisch fix, also zentriert. Ich meine, aus der Ecke
kommt es letztendlich irgendwie, aber du kannst halt mit Jenkins wunderbar alles machen. Deswegen
ich mag Jenkins. Ganz normales GitHub. Deswegen schieben sie jetzt auch alle so Panik, weil
sie festgestellt haben, fuck wir haben Passworte im Klartext, im Repo stehen und das wollen
wir nicht so auf GitHub pushen. Dazu kann ich dann immer nur sagen, heck you, weiß ich
nicht, ob wir das Emote haben, aber das denke ich mir dann immer, wenn ihnen das nach 10
Jahren einfällt. Man denkt schon immer, heck you. Ja, natürlich Private Repo, aber halt
trotzdem auf GitHub. Also falls, das ist G-Bait, ja, aber falls es stimmt, ich sage immer dabei,
dass ich euch nicht meine. Ich meine zum Beispiel euer Kack-Management, die dafür gesorgt haben,
dass das so am Arsch ist, wie es jetzt ist. Ja, mit Sicherheit. Also mehr als ein Handy
würde ich da nicht dran anschließen. Sonst Smokers Smoke. Also wie gesagt, ich habe drei
dieser Steckdosenleisten aktuell im Einsatz. Das macht überhaupt keine Probleme. Eine
liegt im Keller, eine liegt hier hinten auf dem Schreibtisch und eine liegt hier da, hier
hinten, hier seht ihr es ja auch gerade hier, den da. Also überhaupt kein Ding. Welche History?
Ich bin müde. Ich habe auch jetzt geflasht. Eigentlich habe ich überhaupt kein Content
mehr für den Stream. Wir sind durch. Ich habe euch gezeigt, wie man flasht. Habe ich gezeigt,
wie man den Home Assistant einbindet. Mehr kann ich euch heute nicht zeigen. Bedge-Time,
nee noch nicht ganz. Noch nicht ganz Bedge. Aber fast Bedge. Könntest du noch 10 bestellen,
das mache ich auch. Aber nicht on stream. Ich bin hier nicht eingeloggt bei Amazon.
Hey, ich verstehe einiges nicht. Ich verstehe, ich verstehe einiges nicht, was da abgeht.
Was ich auch nicht verstehe. Aber da bin ich mir nicht sicher, Chet. Ihr seid doch schlau.
Ihr wisst da doch bestimmt Bescheid. Also es gibt jetzt ja oftmals so Prämien, wenn
man quasi sein altes Auto verschrotten lässt, um sich ein Elektroauto zu kaufen. Ich meine
klar, dass wenn man quasi vor der Neuanschaffung steht und die Auswahl hat zwischen einem Elektroauto
und einem Verbrennerauto und wenn man auch mal davon ausgeht, dass vielleicht der Strom
demnächst nicht mehr nur mit Kohle oder sonst was hergestellt wird, ist ein Elektroauto
sicherlich für die Zukunft das bessere. Aber es geht ja nicht unbedingt um die Neuanschaffung.
Viele Leute haben ja noch ein altes Auto. Und so wie ich mir das denke, ist es doch
eigentlich das Beste, was man machen kann, dieses alte Auto weiter zu fahren.
Oder ich meine, warum sollte ich quasi was, was hergestellt wurde wegschmeißen? Also
in der Regel ist wegschmeißen und Neuanschaffen doch immer um ein vielfaches, ja wie soll
man sagen, ungesünder. Also verstehe ich den Sinn dahinter gar nicht, dass man sagt,
okay, wenn man jetzt sich ein neues kauft, dass man sich dann ein Elektroauto kauft,
ja das würde ich auch so machen. Also deswegen, das verstehe ich gerade nicht
so ganz, dass alle so scharf drauf sind. Ich meine klar, sie sind so scharf drauf, nicht
der Umwelt zuliebe, was wir eigentlich machen sollten, sondern um Autoverkäufe anzukurbeln.
Ja genau, das denke ich mir auch. Das Beste ist, den Mist zu verwenden. Sag mal so, das
Beste ist erstmal, man braucht gar nichts. Was man nicht hat und nicht benutzt, ist okay.
Aber danach ist es, wenn man es hat, einfach so lang wie es geht zu benutzen. Oh ja und
dann kann man sich was Neues holen. Kannst du einen Passwortmanager? Dein Sub wurde
geknurriert. Oh, habe ich nicht gesehen hier. Exquisite, 3 Monate, 4 Monate Subscription
Tabcon. Ich habe massive, huge Hyper-Subscription hier. Also ich benutze hier KeyPass 2, gibt
aber auch zig andere Passwortmanager. Ich mag halt KeyPass, weil ich schon eine Weile
verwende und für meine rein offline Sachen und Sync auf dem zweiten Rechner funktioniert
das wunderbar. Du hast auch was wie Bitwarden noch selbst gehostet, das ist auch okay. Eigentlich
ist alles, was du selbst in der Hand hast, okay. Was ich auf gar keinen Fall machen würde,
ist Cloud Passwortmanager verwenden. Ich kann das nicht verstehen, wie sich Leute darüber
beschweren, dass, also darüber beschweren kann man sich, aber die dann wirklich darüber
überrascht sind, wenn es dann mal wieder irgendwelche Datenleaks gibt und ihre Passwörter wechseln
und sowas. Cloud Passwortmanager, wenn ihr nicht wisst, was der Anbieter macht und das
wisst ihr nicht, wenn ihr nicht gerade der Anbieter seid. Warum? Warum? Ja, was weiß
ich bei irgendwelchen anderen Dingern, ja, kann man Cloud Services ja verwenden, aber
doch nicht für das Wichtigste aller, was man hat, nämlich die Passwörter. Meinung zu
KeyPass XC habe ich, weiß nicht, ob ich das ausprobiert habe. Ich habe KeyPass 2 seit
Ewigkeiten. Ist nie passiert bei einem, weiß ich nicht. Ich würde aber eher darauf tippen,
dass das schon passiert ist. Leak Cloud Passwort Manager. Passwort Leak. Bäm, das erste, was
ich gefunden habe. Rock You 2021. Wunderbar. Also mich würde, wie gesagt, mich würde,
mich würde nicht wundern, wenn das schon öfters mal vorgekommen ist. Also, wie gesagt,
ich halte nichts von Cloud Passwort Managern, die von anderen Anbietern betrieben werden.
Ja, das ist richtig, sehe ich auch so. Die Bahn muss es geschissen bekommen. Der Chain
Loader ist wieder voller Welleskalieren, Alter. Ja, das sagen die. Hat sich wirklich irgendjemand
mal die Software angeguckt, ob das wirklich so ist? Ob die aktuelle Libraries verwenden
von was auch immer sie zum verschlüsseln. Also ich traue keinem Cloud Passwort Manager.
Es ist auch total unsinnig. Warum soll ich den Scheiß dann in die Cloud legen? Mal ehrlich,
man hat, man hat keine Ahnung. Ich sag mal, man hat 300 Passwörter. Man hat ja mittlerweile
viele Passwörter. Aber mal realistisch überlegt, wie viele dieser 300 Passwörter braucht man
dann wirklich zum Beispiel auf einem Smartphone. Fünf. Warum sollte ich meinen kompletten Passwort
Manager da drauf packen? Im Zweifelsfall nehme ich halt diese fünf Passwörter und
speichere sie dort in irgendeiner App drin. Meinetwegen, wenn ich die mobil brauche, aber
doch nicht den kompletten, aber nicht den kompletten Safe, geschweige denn irgendwie,
das ist doch keine Begründung, warum man es in die Cloud legen sollte. Also wie gesagt,
ich würde nie Passwort Manager in der Cloud verwenden. Ja, ein paar habe ich auch im Kopf
und die sind ziemlich lang. Am besten ist auch geil bei uns auf der Arbeit. Ich muss
das jetzt ein bisschen anders erzählen, oder? Da hatten sie letztens auch irgendein Meeting
so security-mäßig und haben sich überlegt, wenn der Hacker Zugriff auf den Server bekommt,
das machen die bei mir auf der Arbeit gerne. Die sagen dann immer irgendwie so als Begründung,
oh ja, der Hacker macht dann irgendwas, was der genau macht und wer da überhaupt hacken
sollte und was da los ist vollkommen egal. Dann sagt dann immer einer irgendwie sowas,
aber wenn der Hacker Zugriff auf unseren Server bekommt, dann kann er sich das und das angucken.
Da habe ich auch dazu gesagt, aber sehr gut, davor hat der Hacker schon unser Passwort
erraten. Ich meine, wir haben so Passwörter wie Live-Umgebung, das findet er nie raus.
Live-Umgebung, nein, das kann man nicht knacken, das ist unknackbar. Oh nein, das ist kein
wirkliches Passwort von der Arbeit gewesen, das habe ich jetzt geändert im Kopf. Das
ist was ähnliches, aber genauso bescheuert. Also, die machen sich da Gedanken um tausend
Dinger und haben teilweise Passwörter. Da muss nicht der Hacker irgendwie per Zero
Day auf unserem Linux irgendwie was machen. Ne, der probiert fünf Passwörter durch und
ist eingeloggt. Also, ich weiß eh nicht bei uns, was da mit den Leuten teilweise los
ist. Genauso wie ich mal vor einer ganzen Weile, habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt,
gemietet habe und der Typ meinte dann zu mir, wir müssen mit dem Rechenzentrumsteam klären,
wir brauchen da die fetteste Hardware, die wir haben und war da Felix am Start, Felix
so, was haben wir denn da und da Felix meinte so, die fetteste Hardware ist irgendwie zwei
Terabyte RAM oder mittlerweile glaube ich noch mehr, zwei Terabyte RAM, 48 Kerne, das ist
schon ordentlich, das brauchen wir, die fetteste Hardware, wir rechnen mit massiv vielen Zugriffen
und da hatte ich ihn gefragt, ja und, da ging es um irgendwelche komischen WordPress-Seiten,
die sauer interessieren, ja und was, mit was für Zugriffen rechnen wir da so? Da meinte
er so, ich bin mir jetzt, Leute, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie die Zahl genau war,
ja, ich weiß nur noch, wie er das gesagt hat und dann sagt er dann so, 1000 und ich dachte
so, 1000 in der Sekunde oder so, das ist schon, das ist zwar kein, das geht schon, aber das
ist natürlich schon ordentlich und dann meinte er, am Tag, da habe ich dann auch innerlich,
nein, nicht nur innerlich, auch äußerlich gecakt, da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, lass
man Raspberry Pi Zero hinstellen, 1000 am Tag oder es kann auch sein, dass er in der
Stunde gesagt hat oder so, macht keinen Unterschied, also, so lange das nicht in der Sekunde und
selbst in der Sekunde ist das kein Problem, also das geht, dann braucht man vielleicht,
je nachdem was dahinter hängt, tatsächlich bisschen dickere Hardware, aber in der Stunde
oder gar am Tag, also pro Minute schaffst du easy, mit fast jeder Krücke, die es so
gibt, wie gesagt, ich hätte gesagt, wenn er pro Sekunde sagt, dann würde ich sagen, okay,
oh man, wir haben da schon Spezialisten teilweise am Start, da muss ich immer wieder mit dem
Kopf schütteln, aber wisst ihr was das witzige ist, genauso wie ich über die Leute lästere,
lästern die auch über uns, das weiß ich, was mich auch nicht juckt, die haben da wahrscheinlich
sogar recht, die haben da wahrscheinlich sogar recht damit, weil es ist einfach so, 90% der
Leute sind unfähig, das bedeutet 90% unserer Entwickler sind unfähig, das heißt aber auch
90% unserer Admins sind unfähig, ich bin wahrscheinlich auch unfähig, also es ist
halt so, dagegen ist Ping ein Dedos, ja. Habt ihr auch ältere Kollegen, die irgendwie
bei 2005 stehengeblieben sind, die haben kaum alte, also wir haben einen bei uns, der ist
wirklich relativ alt, er geht glaube ich sogar nächstes Jahr in Rente oder so, der ist ein
bisschen schwierig im Umgang, was neue Sachen angeht, vor allem schnell neue Sachen, aber
gut, kann ich verstehen, und ansonsten haben wir eigentlich kaum so richtig ältere, ich
denke, ich denke die meisten sind ungefähr in meinem Alter, also irgendwas zwischen 30
und 40. Schule haben wir teilweise, Windows 2003 Server, mich würde nicht wundern, wenn
es Schulen gibt, die noch Windows 8, 9 haben, gibt's garantiert. Schluck auf, was ist denn
jetzt los, irgendwelche Brennpunktschulen in Berlin oder so, die haben bestimmt noch
Windows 98, die mit Gitter stehen am Klassenzimmer, das ist eine gute Antwort, aber trifft übrigens
auf Führungskräfte genauso zu, man kann eigentlich bei allem, egal in welcher Branche
oder in welchem Fachgebiet davon ausgehen, dass 80 bis 90% unfähig sind, also unfähig
heißt jetzt nicht, dass die gar nichts können, dass aber sobald die Sachen komplizierter
werden, es bei denen aufhört. Das ist egal, ob das Führungskräfte sind, ob das Admins
sind oder ob das Programmierer, Softwareentwickler, was auch immer sind, egal ob es Ärzte sind
oder sonst was, 80 bis 90% ist einfach, ja unfähig ist das falsche Wort, sobald es über
die Standardsachen rausgeht, ist da halt nichts mehr. Was meint ihr denn, warum manche Ausbildungen
so anspruchsvoll und schwierig sind, sei es um Arzt zu werden oder Pilot zu werden oder
um solche Dinge zu machen, das ist kein Wunder, dass die so anspruchsvoll sind, weil die
wollen sicherstellen, dass die 80%, die nix auf die Reihe kriegen, nicht im Endeffekt
dann hinterm Steuer sitzen. Hat er? Was wir als Passwortmanager, oh fuck, ich hab keine
Ahnung, wie das Ding heißt, irgend so einen hässlichen Active Directory basierten Passwortmanager,
der ein ungültiges Zertifikat hat beim Einloggen, wenn man das falsch startet, was auch sehr
vertrauenserweckend ist bei einem Passwortmanager. Ja, ist so, es ist überall so. Secret Zone,
ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das Ding heißt. Also das älteste Linux System, was wir haben,
ist den Red Hat Enterprise Linux 4. Weiß nicht, was da für ein Kernel drin ist. Schauen wir
eben. Ah, yes. Top aktuell. Kernel 269 100. Das ist doch mal pock. Top aktuell. Und wer
hätte das gedacht, es ist in Oracle datenbankbasiertes Warenwirtschaftssystem, was darauf läuft.
Also manche Sachen wirst du halt echt nicht los. Das stimmt nicht. Leute, Leute, ich hab
euch angelogen. Das stimmt nicht, was ich gesagt hab. Das stimmt nicht. Ich hab mich
vertan. Das ist noch viel schlimmer. Es ist, es ist noch viel schlimmer. Das älteste System
ist in Red Hat 5. Es ist in Red Hat 5 das älteste System, was wir haben. Aber es ist
in Red Hat 5 getarnt als Red Hat 4. Die Red Hat Versionsdatei ist angepasst. Das ist in
Red Hat 5. Und in der Versionsdatei steht drin, es ist ein Red Hat 4. Weil die Datenbank,
die da drauf ist, ist so alt, dass sie nur startet, wenn es in Red Hat 4 ist. Und das
älteste, was wir hatten, war glaube ich in Red Hat 5. Und deswegen hat man einfach die
Datei angepasst, dass das startet. Ich erinnere mich. Ja, das stimmt. Red Hat 5 ist das, ist
das älteste, was wir haben. Aber es ist auch nicht wirklich neuer. 2, 6, 18er Körner.
Das, was ihr jetzt hier erfahrt, ist halt so typischer Business-Enterprise-Shit. Da,
da machst du nix, ja. Oh, das ist richtig schöne Bed-Git-Musik, oder? Findet ihr nicht
auch? Debian 8. Das ist auch schon ein bisschen älter. Findest du richtig schöne Bed-Git-Musik.
Allerdings, ich mein, Bed-Git-Time ist noch 50 Minuten hin. Hörst du nix? Excellent Bed-Git.
Ja, ich hab euch jetzt ja schon jede Menge erzählt. Ich überleg grad, ich brauch mal,
ich muss demnächst mal wieder ein neues Story-Video aufnehmen. Und ich bin mir noch nicht ganz
sicher, was ich nehmen soll. Ist schon viel Schwachsinn passiert, aber mir fällt jetzt
grad nix so, so richtig Griffiges ein, was ich als nächstes nehmen könnte. Im Zweifelsfall
Recycle-Story. Irgendwas, was ich hier im Stream schon erzählt hab, noch nicht auf YouTube.
Erster Schultag? Ich kann mich an meinen ersten Schultag nicht mal richtig erinnern. Ich bin
nicht mal sicher, ob ich ne Schultüte hatte. Wahrscheinlich. Erster Schultag muss für mich
relativ unspektakulär gewesen sein. Ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Erster Ausbildungstag. Das weiß ich noch. Erster Ausbildungstag beim Provider. Das weiß
ich noch. Da musste man irgendwelche dummen Kennenlernspielchen machen. Das ist richtig
Pain's Jam gewesen. Das kann ich mir noch dran erinnern. Da musste man durchs ganze Gebäude
rennen und quasi erraten, welcher Mitarbeiter damit gemeint ist und so was. Richtig, richtig
massive Pain's Jam, Alter. Das ist so cringe gewesen. Äh, ja. Könntest du machen. Also
zumindest die User-Seite, also Libraries und sonst was. Der Kernel ist natürlich neuer
dann. Der ist ja der vom Host. Erster Arbeitstag nach Ausbildung. Oh, da kann ich mich tatsächlich
nicht mehr dran erinnern. Aber erster Ausbildungstag kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Das weiß
ich noch. Der, ja, komische Kennenlernspielchen. Das war richtig, richtig Pain's Jam. Ich bin
ja immer noch, ne. Ich hab euch ja die Story erzählt von der Weihnachtsfeier und dem Ausbildungsgrill.
Da ärgere ich mich heute noch. Weil mit der hab ich mich auch wirklich gut verstanden.
Und eigentlich haben wir uns beide, fanden wir uns, glaub ich, ganz nett. Aber ich hab's
halt wieder verpeilt. Ja. Vielleicht ist sie hier im Stream. Nein, hier ist sie garantiert
sie hier nicht im Stream. Die ist garantiert nicht im Stream. Null. Unser Chef was jetzt
zu einer Team-Building-Maßnahme außerhalb der Arbeitszeit? So ein Arsch, Alter. Also
zwingen ist eh schon mal außerhalb der Arbeitszeit so ein Ding. Jungfrau check? Ne, das geht
anders. Poki V check musst du machen. Virgin check, Poki V, I'm safe, das musst du machen.
Virgin check, Poki V, I'm safe. Chat, ich bin mal gespannt, wer den nicht übersteht.
Jetzt will ich sehen, Chat. Auf geht's. Virgin check, Poki V. Jaja, ich weiß. Ach komm, es
ist mittlerweile alles verboten. Okay. Keine Poki-Subs hier. Jetzt enttäuscht mich der
Chat aber. Ich hatte tatsächlich mal einen Monat Pokimane gesubbt. Allerdings hat mir
den Sub jemand gegiftet. Ich weiß bis heute nicht warum und wer das war. Okay, Chat, ihr
habt bestanden. Haben wir nochmal Glück gehabt. Ganz knapp, close. Dann musst du ja im Stream
gewesen haben. Muss man das? Du hast das nicht wirklich gesubbt, oder? Du warst bestimmt
schon vorher gesubbt und du hast nie den Check gemacht. Guck, er hat nie den Check gemacht.
Der war die ganze Zeit schon gesubbt. Exposed der Chandler hier. Gott soll jeder suppen,
jeder will. Ist mir eh noch egal. Ihr könnt auch irgendwelche ASMR-Ear-Licking-Channels
machen. Pool-Streams, wo auf der Banane rumgerutscht wird, kann jeder machen, was er lustig ist,
ist nix. Tja. Ja, das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.
Ja gut, Leute. Ich hab absolut kein Content mehr left für heute. Was ein Scheißsatz,
Alter. Ich hab kein Content mehr left. Also Leute, ich hab kein Content mehr left für
heute. Und geflasht haben wir, hat alles funktioniert. Ich werd mir jetzt nochmal, sag mal, 10 Stück
vielleicht nicht, aber sag mal mal 5 Stück hier. Da, da. Ich kann grad nicht hinkucken.
5 Stück bestell ich mir da nochmal von. Weil Steckdosen-Leisten kann man nie genug haben.
Wie wäre es mit Level-Cap-Chebaten, ey? Was am Sonntag wieder? Was soll man sich da
chebaten lassen bei Level-Cap? Was gibt's denn da? Was chebatet er dann wieder? Warlhex-Specialist
gefixt. Was heißt gefixt? Das Spiel ist doch nimmer raus. Was soll da gefixt werden?
Fix ist eine Fehlerbehebung. Dazu muss es den Fehler erstmal geben, damit man ihn beheben
kann. Oder Spiel gibt's noch nicht. Ich mein, es dauert nicht mal lang. Es dauert noch 10
Tage jetzt. Da, hier, da. Ne. Da. Wer ist eigentlich auf diese unintuitive Geschichte
gekommen, dass ne Woche 7 Tage hat anstatt 10, dass ne Minute 60 Sekunden hat, 60 Minuten
ne Stunde und dann aber 24 Stunden nen Tag und sowas. Könnte man das nicht alles wenigstens
auf 2er oder 10er Basis machen? Und bei der Gelegenheit noch den ganzen Shit mit Zeitzonen
und so einfach sein lassen? Dann wüsste man wenigstens, wie man das rechnen soll und
das wäre alles gut. Das waren sicher die Amis. Ne, ne. Das ist definitiv Pre-Kakona. Die
Amis waren viel zu spät am Start, um Einfluss zu haben auf sowas. Die sind leider zu ner
blöden Zeit am Start gekommen, als Fahrenheit und Galon und ounces und feet noch angesagt
waren und dann hat jeder gesagt, wir wollen den Scheiß nicht mehr, aber die Amis haben
gesagt, na, wir behalten das noch. Ja, right. Können wir Sommer und Winterzeit abschlafen?
Nein, nicht mit der EU. Wir haben abgestimmt, die Leute wollten das haben, aber jetzt kriegen
wir es nicht mehr hin. Ne, ne, ne, ne. So Sachen gehen nicht schnell. Das dauert tausende
Jahre jetzt noch, bis das abgeschaltet wird. Egal Leute, ich geh jetzt off und dann in
der Stunde im Bett gehen.